hello Barbara lights Ryan Finnegan aka
agent M here for Earth's Mightiest show
where III it is the most wonderful time
of the year it is videogame heaven I'm
so excited everybody's talking about
Marvel's Avengers and Marvel Ultimate
Alliance 3 the black order so much fun I
got to share with you guys my favorite
Marvel moments of e3 let's check them
out
we kicked off III 2019 in the biggest
way possible with Marvel's Avengers
revealing the game to the world story
characters actor settings some highs
some lows some tears so much more and
I'm super hyped for the game and for e3
2019 but I'm not the only one hyped for
Marvel's Avengers this week if we were
hyped for the reveal oh boy oh boy we
got so much more here on the show floor
at e3 there is a giant Marvel's Avengers
booth and it is loaded with swag we got
lanyards and dossiers it's got costumes
for the five core Avengers that you can
check out Seaton here put it all leads
to actually getting to see about 30
minutes of gameplay for Marvel's
Avengers and it is mind-blowing we went
inside we saw a lot of cool stuff share
with you what we can oh man but if you
think this is it
no we got so much more to see and do
here at e3 let's check it out
Nintendo's booth has been swamped
throughout III 2019 but we got in here
super early to get exclusive access to
play Marvel Ultimate Alliance 3 the
black order you guys it's so much fun
[Music]
hell yes y'all
what an amazing III so much fun you guys
saw so many cool things going on and of
course make sure you preorder Marvel's
Avengers comes out May 15 2020 on ps4
xbox pc and stadia and of course Marvel
Ultimate Alliance 3 pre-order that comes
out July 19th that's so soon
a Nintendo switch I can't wait and it's
been such a great III we have tons of
coverage on marvel calm this week in
Marvel Marvel let's play pretty much
everywhere it's awesome it's pretty
great III you guys I'll be back with
more soon I'm Ryan and this is Marvel
your universe